The Despicable Me movies are always stuffed
with stacks of pop culture references and
easter eggs that can be lots of fun for fans
to uncover.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and I've scoured Despicable Me 3 for easter
eggs, funny references, plus other cool things
you might have missed, and I'm going to be
revealing all of them in this video.
I've got a bunch of cool merchandise from
the movie to give away.
So, make sure you subscribe and turn on your
notifications, and answer the question I'll
be asking later in the video!
A quick reminder also, that there are some
spoilers in this video, so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet.
Let's kick off with a very cool easter egg
to Illumination's next animated movie "How
The Grinch Stole Christmas" which stars Benedict
Cumberbatch in the title role.
You can spot the grouchy Grinch character
from the movie and the book of the same name
by Dr. Seuss on Margot's T-shirt in Despicable
Me 3.
But this isn't the first time that Illumination
has featured one of their upcoming films in
this way.
If you look back at the first Despicable Me
movie which was released in 2010, you'll see
that Margot wore a T-shirt with a picture
of The Lorax on it, and that character popped
up in his own movie two years later.
Agnes's unicorn obsession continues in Despicable
Me 3 and there's a funny call-back to the
unicorn toy from the funfair in the first
movie that Gru eventually won for her.
In Despicable Me 3, Agnes wanders into the
Tipsy Unicorn bar in Freedonia where she meets
a bartender who apparently has a real unicorn
horn.
And after she grills him about the unicorn,
she demands to know if it was fluffy and he
replies with the same words Agnes said in
the first movie "it was so fluffy, I thought
I was going to die".
"Look at that fluffy unicorn!"
"He's so fluffy I'm gonna die!"
"You saw a for-real-life unicorn?!
What did it look like?"
[GASPS]
"Did you pet it?
Did it smell like candy?!"
"Was it fluffyrrrrrrrrr?!"
"It was so fluffy, I thought I was gonna die."
Villain Con, the supervillain convention for
would-be masterminds and criminals that first
appeared in the Minions movie, gets a shout-out
in Despicable Me 3 via a poster on the wall
during this shot with two minions.
Gru's resident mad scientist Dr Nefario has
appeared in all the Despicable Me movies so
far, including a small cameo in the Minions
movie where a young Nefario showcased his
Freeze Ray to a young Gru and his mother at
Villain Con.
In the third Despicable Me movie though, we
discover that Dr Nefario has accidentally
frozen himself in carbonite, which is an obvious
hat-tip to Han Solo in Star Wars: The Empire
Strikes Back.
Despicable Me 3 introduces a brand new minion
called Mel, who becomes the leader of the
banana-loving mischief-makers.
Given that Mel is the new top minion in town,
it seems totally fitting that he was named
after Chris Meledandri, the big boss and founder
of Illumination.
And notice how when the minions go to prison,
Mel also literally gets number one billing
with 001 on his prison uniform to indicate
he's the head minion.
And Mel is not only named after Illumination
boss Meledandri, but Mel's hairstyle is also
modelled after Meledandri's own hairline!
In fact, Mel's whole design is based on a
birthday card drawing that Despicable Me 3
co-director Eric Guillon did years ago of
Meledandri as a minion.
Mel is, of course, responsible for the minion
rebellion against Gru, but before that, he
played a hilarious montage of photos the minions
put together to try and convince Gru that
being bad is so much more fun than being good.
And in one of those shots we can see Gru stealing
a rare artefact that looks a lot like the
Golden Idol that Indiana Jones stole at the
beginning of Raiders of the Lost Ark.
After almost all the minions leave, Gru and
company travel to Freedonia to meet his twin
brother Dru.
Although Freedonia is a fictitious place,
it's actually a real word that originated
just after the American Revolution and later
became popularised in the Marx Brothers comic
movie Duck Soup about a small country called
Freedonia.
In Despicable Me 3, Freedonia is hilariously
overrun with pigs.
The police ride on pigs rather than horses,
one of the license plates reads "FR33 PIG"
and the ceiling in the entrance hall to Dru's
lavish mansion is, as Lucy puts it, like "the
Sistine Chapel with pigs".
Pigs are also incorporated into almost everything
in Freedonia.
There's a Cheese Invaders arcade game in the
inn, a pig-manned foosball game, Hog Zoda
and Freedo Kola adverts, and does that map
of Freedonia suggest the island is even shaped
a bit like a pig?
Back at Dru's mansion, Dru introduces Gru
to his lair which is full of statues of past
villains from their family.
And as they walk past a gunslinger, if you
look carefully in the next shot, you can just
make out the name at the base of the statue
which is "Grutch Cassidy", a reference to
Butch Cassidy, the real-life Wild West train
and bank robber.
And if we look at the rest of the villains
in this hall of infamy, could that be a Gru
version of Hannibal Lecter?
Over here this clown-looking Gru might be
a nod to the infamous clown Pennywise from
the Stephen King novel IT and its upcoming
big-screen adaptation.
And next to him that looks a bit like Igor,
the classic hunchbacked assistant to Frankenstein
or Count Dracula?
And if that is Igor, it might also be a little
tie in or reference to Universal's Dark Universe
as Universal are the parent company of Illumination
who developed the Despicable Me franchise.
Gru and Dru are, of course, opposites of sorts,
and the Despicable Me 3 filmmakers have described
Dru as the "yin to Gru's yang".
And on this theme, the animators have cleverly
snuck in a variety of yin and yang symbolism
into several scenes involving Gru and Dru.
First of all, the logo on the side of Dru's
Despicamobile is a riff on the classic Yin-Yang
symbol.
And notice how the logo shows up again on
Dru's coffee mug over here.
Gru and Dru's costumes are also black and
white, the same colours that make up the Yin-Yang
symbol, and later when Gru and Dru are up
on the side of Bratt's fortress, they roll
up into a ball that forms the Yin-Yang symbol
thanks to their black and white costumes.
Later, after the brothers get inside Bratt's
fortress, Dru makes a sly reference to one
of my favourite comedy shows.
Steve Carrell, who voices Gru and Dru, is
probably still best known for his portrayal
of Michael Scott in the sitcom The Office.
In Despicable Me 3, after breaking into Bratt's
lair, Dru says he's feeling queasy and that
he shouldn't have eaten that pot pie.
This is a knowing call-back to the season
5 finale of The Office where the whole office
played an elaborate ruse on Michael so they
could go home early when Michael fell asleep
after eating a family-sized pot pie.
Balthazar Bratt is, of course, the new villain
for Despicable Me 3 and thanks to his obsession
with his former fame as a 1980s child star
and his cancelled TV show Evil Bratt, he brings
a large amount of 80s references to the movie.
80s music runs through the whole film and
I particularly liked Bratt's homage to Michael
Jackson's moonwalking while Jackson's 1987
hit "Bad" was playing.
Bratt also makes a clever 80s Hollywood reference
when he unleashes his evil army of Bratt dolls
who he calls the "Bratt Pack".
The Brat Pack (spelled with a single 't')
was a term first used in the 1980s to describe
a group of up-and-coming actors who often
worked together including Emilio Estevez,
Molly Ringwald, and Ally Sheedy.
At one point, Bratt also says "I love it when
a plan comes together", which is a nice reference
to Hannibal's famous catchphrase from the
80s TV series The A-Team.
The giant Dumont Diamond that Bratt steals
at the beginning of the movie is a riff on
the "Pink Panther" diamond from the 1963 movie
which starred Peter Sellers.
Peter Seller's physical comedy and his portrayal
of Inspector Clouseau in The Pink Panther
movies has also been a big influence on all
the Despicable Me movies according to the
franchise's filmmakers, and you can certainly
see they've drawn inspiration from the style
of the Pink Panther films for this movie's
closing credits.
The fart gun from Despicable Me 1 and 2 makes
a brief appearance during the opening Illumination
title when one of the minions barges in and
uses the gun to blast the others.
The Brad & Gary ice cream that appears in
Despicable Me 3 seems like a funny pun on
the famous ice cream brand Ben & Jerry's,
but it's also an easter egg to Illumination's
short film "Brad & Gary" which was directed
by Despicable Me 3 director Pierre Coffin
who also voiced the character of Brad in that
short film, and is, of course, the voice of
the minions as well.
Illumination's previous movie Sing gets a
fairly obvious shout-out when the Minions
run into a recording studio where a musical
talent show called "Sing" is being filmed,
and, on the way in to the show, they also
run past some Sing billboards outside.
Inside the studio, the Minions put on a pretty
spectacular performance with their own interpretation
in Minionese of the "Modern Major-General's
Song" from the Gilbert and Sullivan comic
opera The Pirates of Penzance.
The Minion dance routine during the song also
made me think back to the wonderful sausage
factory scene in Illumination's The Secret
Life of Pets, both of which were partly inspired
by the renowned musical choreography of Busby
Berkeley.
Later, during the scenes where Bratt's giant
robot is terrorising Hollywood, you can see
billboards advertising an "Onions" movie.
Now, given that one of the ads for that film
says 'Coming Soon' and the fact that its title
sounds rather like a play on the word Minions,
I think this is a clever tease to the Minions
2 movie coming in 2020.
Another Hollywood billboard was for "Fast
Car Driver 12", a bit of a joke at the long-running
Fast & Furious franchise which is owned by
Illumination's parent company, Universal!
I also chuckled at the "Giganotosaurus Wrecks"
billboard, clearly a wordplay combination
of the two dinosaurs Giganotosaurus and Tyrannosaurus
Rex, both of which are part of another current
Universal Studios movie franchise, Jurassic
World.
The billboard easter eggs are a fun way for
Illumination to reference franchises owned
by their parent company Universal, but I think
they may have also enjoyed poking fun at one
of their major animation rivals, Pixar, during
the underwater scene at the beginning of the
movie when a pair of clownfish suddenly appear
out of nowhere.
Gru, Lucy and the minions blast past the clownfish
on their way to stop Balthazar Bratt from
stealing the Dumont Diamond.
The moment does feel a bit on the nose and
perhaps a little joke at Pixar's Finding Nemo
and Finding Dory.
So, which easter egg in Despicable Me 3 did
you like the best and were there any I missed?
And, if there's another sequel, what would
you like to see happen in Despicable Me 4?
For a chance to win this awesome Despicable
Me 3 merchandise, be sure to subscribe, and
leave a comment about the movie, and also
answer the following question:
In Despicable Me 3, what substance was Dr
Nefario accidentally frozen in?
Make sure you turn on your notifications to
get all my new animation and easter egg videos
where I'll be announcing the winners of the
giveaway.
And let me know what movie easter eggs you'd
like me to do in a future video.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that thumbs-up button and check out
some more of my videos right here.
Congratulations to the winner of my Beauty
And The Beast giveaway who is on the screen
now!
If that's you, send me a message on YouTube
or via my email on my About page so I can
get your details to send you the prize.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!